the jurogan experience
what is it about
that feeling of discomfort that brings
you
joy or what that that you enjoy giving
to to people that are reading your stuff
is it just
that you don't like
the cliche
sloppy endings of the where everything
is going to be fine and everything's
great and
the world is
different in literature than it is in
real life like what is it about
these moments like these moments of
darkness where you do break everybody's
heart
why do you enjoy them so much
i enjoy them because they prove i'm not
the only one
i'm not the only one that's had these
moments of complete
humiliation or complete powerlessness
one story i've always loved is my best
friend in college
his father was this mining professor and
this very super macho guy and my best
friend franz was like the sun that just
wasn't turning out right
and in their household they had a bunch
of kids girls and boys and one day
franz's dad had all of his his beard
drinking football buds over to watch the
super bowl
and franz found this old doll that had
been around the house for for decades it
was called [ __ ] and it barely had a
hair left on its little doll head
and frond sat there as maybe a five or
six year old little boy
and he very carefully untangled sissy's
hair and he back combed it and he teased
it and he dressed it into a big bouffant
and even got one of his mother's
brooches and he put that brooch through
the front of this beehive hairdo to hold
it in place very marie antoinette
and he was so proud that he turned this
really decrepid
ugly thing into something passively
pretty he had sort of redeemed it
and then he took it to his father in
front of all of his father's friends in
the super bowl and he said daddy daddy
look i made [ __ ] pretty
and his father was so humiliated
that he beat franz right there
in front of
their whole peer group
he just beat france
the story is so painful
but everybody's had a pain like that
everybody has done that that thing out
of innocence and expression
that for whatever reason
got you slammed
and nobody talks about it
nobody talks about it because it's so
painful and because everyone thinks
they're the only one
and so if i can take some of those
stories and bring them to light
it creates this opening for everyone to
say oh my god
i once did this thing
and my parents reacted badly to it or
it destroyed my life and i've never been
the same
and when franz told me that story he was
almost weeping but he was laughing as he
was telling the story
because he had to keep laughing in order
to keep telling the story
and that's what i'm always shooting for
those are the moments like those kind of
stories
are the ones that hit people the hardest
because you know that the child has no
idea that what they're doing is going to
be uncomfortable for anybody like they
have real pride in it
like uh he is a parallel is a story that
you told before uh i guess three years
ago when you were talking about
the writing workshop that you had done
where uh
you were talking about someone else's
story about how they were jacking off in
a jacuzzi and their anus got prolapsed
and this woman in the writing workshop
felt comfortable enough because you told
that story to tell her story about being
in the girl scouts or the brownies the
brownies before the girl scouts the
heating
pad store where she had put this
vibrating heating pad on her vagina and
had her friends do the same thing and
the mom came home and she was only seven
years old she thought it was cool like
look i found this thing
and then the mom beat her with the wire
that was plugged into the wall and
called her a dirty [ __ ] and she never
orgasmed again
and she said
in summation that if i could tell the
story that i had just told that was so
so uh
self-debasing and so humiliating but
also make it funny
then that would that gave her proof that
she could make her own story funny and
that maybe she could someday go back to
her mother and say remember the heating
pad and that maybe ultimately she could
have an orgasm
because
until you can kind of reveal these
things and resolve them
they run the rest of your life and
you're never going to get beyond them
yeah
especially when you don't see it coming
when you're just a child and then you do
something that you think
is totally fine and all of a sudden
you're getting the [ __ ] beaten out of
you
and you don't understand why
all you did is make a doll pretty like
what happened well and it's
it occurs in so many different ways
uh
several years ago i got a job house
sitting a farm that was famous for being
haunted it had all these paranormal
studies
so as soon as the owners were gone i
invited a bunch of psychics out to do a
seance and i wanted to know
and
my father had been murdered about five
years before that
and one of these psychic women that i
had never met before
said there is a man standing with you
he's wearing a white t-shirt
and he's holding something wooden
and he is really really sorry he did
what he did
but he was in a very very young man at
the time he was only 23 or 24. he's
holding something wooden and he's about
to dismember you
does that make any sense whatsoever
and i just kind of nodded my head and i
said i have no idea what you're talking
about
but when i was
maybe three or four years old
my mother had taken my siblings into
town and i was you know in our rural
farm and i put a fender washer around
one of my fingers
and i couldn't get it off and so i
waited until a finger was swollen up and
turning sort of purple black
and i went to my father and i said can
you help me with this
washer thing
and my father had said
i can help you but i want you to learn a
lesson
that you have to there are consequences
to everything you do
and i will help you
with a washer
if you accept responsibility for your
actions for the rest of your life
and he took me and we had to wash the ax
that we killed chickens with we had this
hatchet and he took me and we sharpened
the hatchet and we washed it really
thoroughly so there were no germs on it
and then he had me kneel down by the
chopping block and put my hand on the
chopping block
and
at the time there was no drama it was
just complete clarity my father was
helping me to resolve the situation
and at the last moment he missed my hand
with the axe the axe went into the
chopping block and then we went inside
and used
dish soap to take the washer off
and i knew that story would just make my
mother insane
so i never told anybody my entire life
that story watch the entire episode for
free only on spotify